c'est non non nous allons donc
maintenant écouter le procureur de la
république
le procureur général de la gouaille des
proches de multipro général je vais
requérir violemment nous eh bien
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri e merci
un crépuscule rouge et noir tombait
comme un rideau de malheur sur le mont
des oliviers ce soir maudit ou jus d'un
immonde et furtif s'approcha du fils de
l'homme pour le désigner à ses bourreaux
par un baiser vis d'eux un baiser
leadeuse c'était en l'an 33 arranger ce
que c'était alain 33 après enfin c'était
dans les 33 pendant juste pendant
jésus-christ j'ai essayé pendant mes
avait plus pour longtemps que j'ai ainsi
judas trahit-il le christ les sites ne
riez pas et c'est sur les traces de
judas mesdames et messieurs les jurés
que victor lanoux vingt siècles plus
tard a trahi la france
toute la vie de victor lanoux est
jalonnée d'infamie mesdames et messieurs
les jurés sept hommes a trahi tous là et
la rai toulalan le jour même de sa
naissance le goût de la trahison était
en lui ce jour là comme sa maman lui
tendait le sein droit
il lui mordille cingo de stupeur la
pauvre femme se ramassent à une pelle et
comme on était le 18 juin à 36 ce fut
l'appel du 18 juin à l'école le petit là
nous grâce à des dons exceptionnels
gravit rapidement tous les échelons du
savoir qui mène au certificat d'études
mais la culture n'est pas tout monsieur
lanoux et le fait de savoir que jeanne
d'arc est morte à sainte hélène en
15/100 15 d'étrangers de bonne moralité
comme le disait si bien le chancelier
hitler qui sous des dehors vous rue
cachette un coeur d'or c'est vrai c'est
bon c'est aussi le play il ne suffit pas
d'être cultivé encore faut-il être blanc
bon encore faut-il être bon dans ses pas
hitler c'est gicquel or le ciel à nous
n'est pas bon il est mauvais il est
génétique au biologiquement traître
quand il affirme avoir commencé sa
carrière comme machiniste de plateau il
n'avoue pas tout l'infâme en fait il
était machiniste de plateaux de fruits
de mer médaille
palenfo retoucher un écailler après les
cahiers du cinéma évidemment et c'est là
qu'il passait son temps à bourrer de
microfilms les huîtres destiné à
l'ambassade soviétique
oh certes personne ne lui soupçonnait
c'est un jeune homme tout droit il
réservait disait son patron il oubliait
d'ajouter tout droit est réservé pour
tout pays y compris l urss tard quand le
sieur là nous parvint à s'immiscer dans
la carrière cinématographique grâce à
ses relations judéo marxiste on le
retrouve uniquement dans des rôles
frappé du sceau de l'infamie le plus
abject c'est d'abord la vieille dame
indigne avec jacques chazot dans le rôle
principal
lane où il campe côte sous la tente et
céleri et nos abris non content de non
content de s'en prendre aux bonnes
moeurs victor lanoux ivre de rage et de
boue va désormais choisir au cinéma des
rôles où l'image de la france éternelle
apparaîtra glos qui est ternie et c'est
dupont lajoie qui nous le montrant pas
raciste raciste comme s'il y avait des
parachutistes racisme adieu poulet où il
joue un policier véreux laurent righi un
politicien d'un politicien véreux merci
la mort d'un guide ou l'honnêteté
journalistique en prend plein et
odieusement bafoués mais je vous le
demande monsieur là nous qui aurait
gagné à dien ben phu ci avait pas eu les
paras qui aurait résolu la sphère de
bras et s'il n'y avait pas eu les
politiciens qui seraient au courant de
la ménopause trafic et solitaire de
farah diba s'il n'y avait pas ici paris
et france dimanche
évidemment il a aussi fallu théâtre le
siu lan où vous avez joué dans le cheval
de françoise sagan c'est ça évanoui
évanoui à cheval évanoui voilà il joue
dans l'ain cheval évanoui
déjà que c'est pas très joli tout est
dans un cheval laisser d'acheter dans un
cheval évanoui
elle est belle votre vie privée monsieur
là nous je lis dans votre biographie que
vous êtes marié avec trois enfants
vous pouviez pas où marié à trois femmes
comme tout le monde pour terminer je
vous dirais et victor lanoux
en vérité je vous le dis vous n'auriez
jamais dû monter à paris
à quoi bon avoir été élevé dans la
creuse si c'est pour s'abaisser dans la
plaine sur président j'en ai terminé
je demande la peine de mort je voudrais
que l'accusé soit guillotiné par les
pieds comme les traite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait étonnant non